saludamos a nuestro segundo invitado el
día él es Jaime rival y agua presidente
de la fundación para la investigación
del clima fic con él vamos a hablar
sobre el calentamiento global de las
consecuencias que esto tiene para
nuestro planeta Y por supuesto la
existencia de nosotros los humanos y es
que según la administración nacional
oceánica atmosférica de Estados Unidos
todo nuestro planeta registró en el año
pasado 2022 el sexto año más cálido es
de 1880 las cifras convierten a 2022 en
el sexto año más caliente desde que se
tienen todos los registros y mantiene
también esta tendencia cálida en la que
se encuentra nuestro planeta Gracias
Jaime por estar con nosotros en directo
América de France 24 con estas cifras y
también la tendencia al alza en estas
temperaturas podemos atajar el
calentamiento global para así evitar
consecuencias catastróficas para los
humanos como ya la estamos viendo
Efectivamente es una una prueba más
de que el calentamiento
está siendo muy Severo y que
efectivamente tenemos que tomar medidas
muy muy rápidamente porque se nos va
acabando el tiempo es cierto que
científicamente tenemos que hacer
todavía estamos en ello ahora haciendo
lo que se llaman estudios de atribución
que permiten separar los impactos del
cambio climático de origen humano la
influencia de ese origen humano de la
variabilidad natural que sabemos que
existe y que hay cambios en la en la en
las condiciones meteorológicas por la
variabilidad natural pero los cambios
están siendo tan severos que bueno los
primeros resultados indican que
efectivamente
solo se pueden explicar estos cambios
por la influencia del ser humano en el
clima por el cambio climático estamos
causando y como ahí es el quinto sexto
año más cálido a escala planetaria pero
en Europa es probablemente
en la mitad
Sur occidental de Europa es el año más
cálido del régimen desde que hay
registros en España Francia Inglaterra
Reino Unido Italia en la mayoría
prácticamente todos los países del
Mediterráneo O sea que ha sido un año
extremadamente cálido y el invierno
también ha sido muy Muy cálido Sí el
invierno con unas temperaturas
inusualmente altas Incluso como lo
decíamos Al principio para vender este
tema a nuestra audiencia estaciones de
esquí también han tenido que cerrar por
la falta de nieve pero pues digamos que
eso es un tema leve para la gravedad que
esto supone para la gravedad que supone
el aumento de las temperaturas Y estos
estas salsas de las temperaturas
inusualmente hablando para la fauna la
flora de todo el ecosistema que ya
habita efectivamente Porque estos
cambios en la temperatura al final tiene
un impacto en los ecosistemas tremendo
las las plantas que están
siguiendo su ciclo su ciclo anual pues
de repente estas temperaturas que aquí
aquí en España en Europa hemos estado en
invierno casi como en otoño Incluso si
es que se podía ir a la playa en algunas
zonas Pues realmente Eso hace que el
ciclo vital de plantas y animales se vea
muy muy muy afectado y los impactos son
muy claros los impactos de los cambios
ya se sabe por el acuerdo de país que un
aumento de temperatura de un grado y
medio con respecto a la media Pues los
expertos indican que tendrá unos
impactos de difícil vuelta atrás y este
año ha sido un año de del orden de tres
grados de temperatura más alto en
algunos países en España por ejemplo ha
sido un promedio de tres grados
prácticamente 300 de los 365 días del
año la temperatura ha sido superior a lo
normal en esa época del año o sea que
realmente ha sido tremendo claro
imágenes que estamos viendo de los
incendios es otro otro ejemplo clarísimo
ha sido el año con mayor registro
de emisiones por incendios en un montón
de países europeos y no solo los que
siempre digamos tenemos ese tipo de
problemas en España en Francia Italia
Grecia que tenemos todos los años y no
en países como Alemania o eslovenia que
es un problema que está empezando a ser
Severo ahora y y todo como digo pues
falta hacer los últimos estudios Pero
todo es atribuible el cambio climático
Jaime la solución es que podemos
implementar para que esto no siga
sucediendo para que esta tendencia al
alza en las temperaturas no se mantenga
en este 2023 que pareciera que la van a
superar incluso de las del año pasado
Sí si ahora hay algunos algunos
comentarios de expertos que dicen Bueno
pues el verano que hemos pasado será un
verano normal dentro de unas décadas
Entonces
tenemos que saber a qué nos enfrentamos
no y las soluciones pues son las que
sabemos la fundación para la
investigación del clima ya va trabajando
en esto desde desde 1992 y ya en el 97
generamos una simulaciones de cómo iba a
ser el clima del futuro que son muy
parecidas a las que estamos viendo y a
las que se siguen simulando y desde hace
20-30 años sabemos que la solución está
en reducir emisiones tenemos que reducir
emisiones pero lamentablemente pues
hemos sido mucho más lento de lo que
deberíamos incluso todavía pues aunque
se van haciendo avances sin duda Pero
todavía deberíamos ir más rápido
entonces bueno sí es cierto que los
expertos ya vamos mostrando que estamos
ya en el límite de las de las
posibilidades de no superar esos
umbrales que se marcaban como como
limitantes y que y que realmente urge
que tanto en mitigación que es reducir
las emisiones como en adaptación que es
hacer estudios para ver cómo va a
afectar esto Este cambio climático a los
diferentes sectores Para proponer
medidas de adaptación Pues sinceramente
tenemos que ir muchísimo más deprisa y
con mucha más intensidad hasta el Metal
también hablemos de las cumbres del
clima de la ONU que digamos que cada año
que pasa se hace más difícil no
encontrar un consenso lo vimos en la
Cumbre pasada en Egipto esta Cumbre con
28 que vamos a ver en el mes de
noviembre si va a realizar en emiratos
árabes Unidos y precisamente el
presidente de la estatal pretoriada abu
dabi va a ser el presidente y esta
Cumbre del clima si bien es cierto hay
que trabajar de la mano con las
compañías petroleras y de y de
extracción de energía fósil como puede
hacer todo esto una energía limpia
cuando sabemos que esto es casi
imposible
Sí eso es bueno hay nosotros la verdad
es que somos partidarios de subir al
tren a todos los
factores posibles porque realmente
necesitamos que los actores económicos
se convenzan vean se les demuestre que
efectivamente el cambio climático
también les va a tener un impacto
económico y que precisamente pueden
pueden aprovechar el cambio climático
digamos para para adaptarse y y tener no
tener pérdidas prevenir de pérdidas
económicas no O sea que somos
partidarios de que se incorpore todos
todos son bienvenidos por supuesto si se
hace de una manera honesta y que no sea
lo que se llama el greenworking que hay
también Lamentablemente pues bastante
entidades que se que se incorporan un
poco para lavar su imagen pero que no no
digamos no trabajan en el fondo en
intentar solucionar el problema en serio
pero yo creo que todos son bienvenidos
sobre las cumbres pues evidentemente las
cumbres han servido mucho unas más que
otras y han permitido alcanzar a
acuerdos que han sido muy positivos pero
es cierto que que vamos más lento de lo
que deberíamos y como las evidencias
científicas son cada vez más
indudables más más evidentes No hay
prácticamente ya dudas ninguna pues
las últimas Cumbres pues se pone más de
manifiesto que están yendo más lento de
lo que debería porque ya claro teníamos
que ir mucho más rápido y Bueno pues
hace unos años pues se avanzaba poco y
como tampoco éramos conscientes la
sociedad en general de la gravedad ya
digo que los científicos y claro éramos
pero ahora que están evidente por parte
de todos Pues digamos que se queda un
poco más decepcionado uno de que no se
haya avanzado más rápido
es muy difícil porque sí coordinarnos
todos es muy difícil pero bueno ahora
recientemente ha salido una noticia que
hemos corregido el casi del todo el
agujero de la capa de ozono sí que era
un problemón también y Oye la humanidad
de acuerdo para reducir las emisiones de
unos productos y lo hemos conseguido y
que no vamos a cumplir esto claro
ponérselo y de y darle la prioridad
necesaria